long time ESPN commentator John Saunders  dies at 61 SportsCenter anchor Hannah  Storm made the emotional announcement  live on air our generous and talented  and beloved colleague John Saunders has  died John is one of the most familiar  on-air faces at ESPN you know him he has  been at ESPN for nearly 30 years  Saunders covered college football  basketball and NHL for the network and  was a fixture as co-anchor of  SportsCenter in a statement John skipper  president of ESPN offered this sentiment  quote John was an extraordinary talent  and his friendly informative style has  been a warm welcome to sports fans for  decades he was one of the most  significant and influential members of  the ESPN family as a colleague and  mentor and he will be sorely missed our  sympathy love and support goes out to  all of those who loved and respected our  colleague John Saunders